well,
an express clinic of the university medical center
opens its doors inside
the airport they want me, how are you
greeted by cristian casseres this clinic
will serve for emergencies for travelers
arriving and leaving las vegas it
is located on the second floor
of terminal 1 passengers will be able to see
a doctor from 8 in the morning
until 8 at night can also get
a kobe 19 screening test i
tell you that the genres in sober
night are going through a
strict process of kobe protocols the
american hockey league announced that
Friday night's game in Bakersfield
will not take place The league did not specify
how many players were affected or
exactly from which team
State leaders are asking
residents to get vaccinated against the new
strain or macro and also asking
parents to  protect your
children with available vaccines
anyone over 5 years of age is
eligible to receive the vaccine co  Against
the cob and 19 health experts say that
even if he is vaccinated, the mask will continue to be
used for a while longer and we
close the work week with
pleasant temperatures here we
present the forecast with
temperatures in the low 70s it is the cold
little by little you will feel the  lower
temperatures
we have a slight chance of rain
by the end of next
week a small system that we will be
monitoring and of course we will have more
information for you next week I am
Cristian Cásseres with long-suffering
information on elimina or in Spanish
good day